last night on The Voice unless of course
your name is Blake Shelton he's only got
two contestants left in the game so just
leave it to Blake's fellow coaches and
even his girl wins to finding control
Blake every chance that they get
including with our Casa de Lora he's
been floundering the entire season he's
totally a loser this season oh how would
it feel to lose to the ladies including
your girlfriend Gwen I like girls a lot
more than a lot guys
so I would rather I'd rather lose to
them yeah and not if I lost to John who
I just saw dancing like a sexy dance and
an elf costume that would be upsetting
first takes the People's Sexiest Man
Alive title and now the voice
championship okay like just go ahead and
kick me heard you got a cavity I'm
depressed come on Blake this week is all
about being grateful come Thanksgiving
all the coaches will be living their
best lives away from LA we all fly out
to Oklahoma it's like 30 of us we're
probably gonna be doing a Cheetos turkey
taking all the Stefani's and and then
the Shelton bunch are gonna meet up
there same thing you're doing in Montana
just getting away I just you know I do
agree that getting out of this city like
I didn't grow up in a city so like I
grew up in the countryside so it's nice
I like the escape of getting out in like
trees we rented a house in Palm Springs
do the kids cook at your house Luna
helps she's she bags the house then
after the holidays it's back to work for
Kelly 20 20 is going to be the busiest
year ever
she's got the voice her talk show and
starting April 1st a new Vegas residency
oh why was now a moment like this the
time to do a residency nice tie-in I
really still want to do shows and haha
I love the will of fortune slot machines
and that's where I was winning all my
paychecks
Kelly will take over the Planet
Hollywood theater when Gwen wraps her
just a girl residency any advice for her
I think she just needs to make sure she
puts hand sanitizer on her stage it's
Vegas like there's a lot of germs she
says keep hand sanitizer on deck oh that
is that's true just now in general you
know kids are like petri dishes of
sickness just waiting to explore your
body
[Music]